المستجدات في مخيم جبالي الذي يبدو ان
المواجهات فيه على
شدها طبعا منذ هذا الصباح هناك محاولات
تقدم لقوات الاحتلال في عده محاور هنا في
شمال قطاع غزه في المناطق الشرقيه لجبال
وللمختار الشماليه لشمال قطاع غزه لكن
الاشتباكات بين المقاومه الفلسطينيه وقوات
الاحتلال اشتدت في هذا الصباح في المناطق
الشرقيه لجبال واستمرت لساعات حتى هذه
اللحظه وقد اعلنت المقاومه وكتائب القسام
انها تخوض هذه الاشتباكات وانها قامت
بتفجير عدد من الاليات في هذا المكان ايضا
هناك قصف متواصل من قبل الطائرات الحربيه
بشكل مباشر على منازل المواطنين في
المناطق الشرقيه لجبال خلال هذه
الاشتباكات وما زال مستمر حتى هذه اللحظه
ايضا القصف المدفعي لم يتوقف نهائيا من
مدفعيه الاحتلال على عده مناطق على بيت
لاهيه وعلى شرق جباليا وعلى بيت حانون وما
زال مستمر حتى هذه اللحظه ايضا هنا على
محور اخر هناك محاولات تقدم من الاتجاه
الغربي لمنطقه لتوام لاليات وقوات
الاحتلال في هذه المنطقه حيث تم انتشال
ثلاث شهداء من هذه المنطقه وتم ايصالهم
الى مستشفى كمال عدوان بعد اطلاق النار
عليهم بشكل مباشر من قبل قوات الاحتلال
طبعا منذ هذا الصباح القصف لم يتوقف
والقصف المدفعي مستمر حتى هذه اللحظه
وهناك محاولات تقدم من قبل قوات الاحتلال
في عده محاور هنا في شمال غزه لكن هنا
المقاومه تحاول التصدي لهذه التقدمات وتخض
اشتباكات ضاريه بينها وبين قوات الاحتلال
وتم تفجير عدد من الاليات شرق جباليا وحتى
هذه اللحظه الاشتباكات لم تتوقف ايضا هناك
اطلاق نار كثيف من قبل طائرات اكوات كابتر
على منازل المواطنين وعلى كل من يحاول
التحرك في المناطق الشرقيه لجبال ومخيم
جباليا ولبيت لاهيه وايضا لمنطقه لتوام
هناك مواطنين يحاولون الوصول لمنازلهم في
هذه المناطق لكن طائرات الاحتلال تقوم
باطلاق النار عليهم بشكل مباشر في هذه
الاماكن اها